c'est impossible
j'ai eu la glace j'ai pas eu mon whisky
je lui en veux parce que tu as été il a
été méchant hier il était très
désagréable j'aurais pu être pire
bonhomme comment ça tu aurais pu être
pire j'ai une coloscopie de ta mère
filmer du bout de ma
Bigard allez tu sais que si j'enlève un
B ça fait un gars
oui mais faut enlever le B justement
hein
c'est une chambre c'est quoi c'est il
m'en veut mais je vais vous dire
pourquoi il m'en veut parce que la
dernière fois il est venu dans
l'émission et tu t'es énervé parce que
je t'ai foutu un passage je sais plus
qui t'avait énervé et tu as crié machin
et tout et tu m'en avais juste pour ça
si parce que tu as arrêté sur tes
réseaux de de communiquer le passage où
j'avais les narines gonflées j'étais
ridicule allez faites voir bisous
[Applaudissements]